[Musique]
non
la nuit des guerriers qui dure toute une
nuit complète akadora sion enseignement
où ces hommes qui semblent être des
guerriers du seigneur des guerriers de
l'amour bien sûr et bien sont amenés à
entendre écouter à réfléchir et je vends
à changer de comportement pour que
justement l'année démarre sur une lancée
d'évangélisation mais aussi le de
conversion y aura des temps de louange
des temps de réflexion un exempt
saignements des prises de paroles mais
aussi des temps d'adoration silencieuse
ou là devant le saint sacrement devant
jésus christ vivant et bien nous nous
laissons enseignée par lui nous
l'écoutons et bien sûr de la demie ronde
val d'auron et nous nous reconnaissons
que sans lui ne sommes pas grand chose
[Musique]
puis on sent bien que ça répond début
d'année à
les goûts plus dans les familles mais
aussi pour les hommes
passionnément un choix et désire nuit
venue passer pour le seigneur pour
lancer son son année pastorale aussi et
puis quelque chose entre nous entre
hommes pour construire ce le royaume de
dieu plus de monde plus deux frères plus
de jeunes ça veut dire que la formule
marche
aujourd'hui quand même lui
grosse affluence
[Musique]
des doublés certaines d'activité on
on n'a pas fait les années précédentes 2
autre raffinement de la présence des
hommes et de leur prise de possession
j'en veux dire de la foi mais aussi de
leurs de leur place dans l'église et
dans la famille
la société donc quelque chose de très
positif est vraiment
[Musique]
et